oh good morning Hank it's Sunday wait is
it morning is it Sunday why am I the
world's smallest bathroom sorry I think
I just got the Holland and I haven't
slept in 34 hours and I don't know
what's going on
Oh reminder there's an Amsterdam
nerdfighter gathering Thursday night at
7 o'clock it DRN more info in the side
bar wherever that is too tired okay now
I have to make a video about genocide
which isn't funny sorry
hey this year marks the 15th anniversary
of the Rwandan genocide I'm not really
going to talk about the genocide or what
happened nerdfighters if you want to
know about it you should read the first
book that Hank and I read for the
Brotherhood 2.0 Book Club we wish to
inform you that tomorrow we will be
killed with our families a book that is
literally as good as its title is long
but I didn't want to say two things
about genocide first thing I recognized
that everyone as opposed to genocide
it's like being opposed to childhood
cancer or unicorns being opposed to
genocide is obvious it's uncomplicated
and it's easy and the second thing I
want to say about genocide is that even
though being opposed to it is obvious
and easy it's still important
Hank obviously there's a lot to lament
about what happened in Rwanda 15 years
ago but lately I find myself thinking a
lot about the abandonment that was
involved hang fifteen years ago the u.s.
the UN and Europe got almost all of our
people out of Rwanda unharmed and the
hundreds of thousands of people who were
killed were left to conclude that they
weren't our people that they were of
them and so in 15 years later it seems
to be very valuable to say to the people
of Rwanda you are not them you are us
and in our shared regret and sorrow we
acknowledged the immensity of your loss
and we share your hope for the future of
your country anything as it happens we
have a super amazing opportunity to do
this nerdfighteria and alliance with the
Harry Potter Alliance can you have an
alliance with an alliance is going to
come together to make tons and tons of
videos for the people of Rwanda all the
videos that we make are going to go on
the website handles for Rwanda org and a
few of them will be played in Rwanda a
huge ceremony on April 7th and now Hank
world's smallest hotel bathroom I'm
going to show you in the nerdfighters
how to make your video for Rwanda step 1
get a candle I don't have a candle but I
do have this television remote control
pretend this is a candle don't use a
television remote control use an actual
candle also remember fire safety step 2
videotape yourself saying some variation
of my name is John I'm 26 years old I'm
from the United States and I'm lighting
a candle of hope for Rwanda then
silently hold your candle for five to
ten seconds step three send your videos
by you send it to videos at the HP
Alliance org link in the sidebar
hang on pu and lots of nerdfighters will
light a candle for rwanda and send your
video and I know that I'm going to just
as soon as I have a candle that's not a
remote control Hank I'll see you on
Tuesday nerdfighters I'll see many of
you in Amsterdam on Thursday and I
promise to make an Amsterdam Eve video
by the end of the week dftba